epic games to support a creator code
program is a cool way for a fortnight
fans to throw cash at their favorite
content creators but what happens when a
major streamer shares a name with
somebody you've probably never heard of
well what happens is a small-time
youtuber gets to keep 26 grand that fans
thought they were donating to somebody
else so back in 2018 epic games launched
the supporter creator program which was
aimed primarily at fortnight content
creators the basic idea is is that fans
of a specific creator can enter that
creators code when they're buying stuff
in the fortnight or at the game store
and that creator gets a cut it's a
pretty good idea and opens up a new
avenue for content creators to support
themselves financially now literally
anybody can apply for a creator code
which as you've seen a minute is a bit
of a problem see as long as you have a
thousand plus followers on at least one
major social media platform and epic
games doesn't think you suck yeah you
can get a code - okay so enter sway not
phase way the guy you might have heard
of just sway a small-time youtuber in
the UK so early on in the program sway
applied for the creator code sway and
since he had more than a thousand subs
epic gave it to him but when phase sway
applied for a creator code a few days
later naturally he couldn't take sway so
instead he chose yo sway it's kind of
like those weirdos who sit on popular
domain names until people with money
come calling to buy them and you can
probably guess what happened next when
the shop changed art we'd use coats when
someone replied calling me a fanboy and
that's not my code and then I realized
like people were using the wrong code
you know but a dustman face weight
didn't have a code so people thought
that was his code and then when he
promoted his code it dropped but still
people were using my code thinking it's
his code yeah fans at face way
accidentally donated over 26 grand to
the guy I'm now gonna call fake sway
because nobody could figure out whose
creator's code was whose I just told you
that listen listen how dare you point at
me who you were pointing first rude to
point you're being very rude now here's
the thing fake suede technique
didn't do anything wrong it might be a
little scuzzy that he's still collecting
coin on the mistakes of face wave fans
but he hasn't broken any of Epix rules
which begs the question how does Epic
Games change the support of creative
code program so stuff like this doesn't
happen so I have no idea if fans who
donated and correctly got refunds or if
there's even a process for that kind of
thing but there really should be one
also apparently phase sway knows all
about this weird situation and frankly
doesn't care since he's still making
money
I spoke to face way about he like when
he got his code like the third day he
got his coated DME and that's how many
suppose I had and then he like tripled
the money round in three days and he
said he doesn't care well this is being
pretty funny up until this point things
kind of get crazy here so just stick
with me so fake sway was once friends
with a fortnight content creator named
orange guy despite having more
subscribers orange guy was apparently
having trouble getting response from
epic in terms of getting a creator code
so he asked fakes wave for help now just
to be clear I've reached out to orange
guy on Twitter and while he declined an
interview we've gone back and forth
extensively over DMS okay so fake sway
got orange guy the Creator code orange
using sways epic games account now this
in and of itself doesn't seem aboveboard
because as far as I know you can't have
multiple creator codes connected to one
epic games account according to orange
guy this Creator code was for him he
gave fake sway all of his info including
his tax information and I mean just
don't do that and here's where things
get super screwy
according to orange guy fake sway gave
him 13 K and donations from people who
use creator code orange
and he gave fake sway $1,000 for helping
him out but then apparently the duel had
a falling out and when orange guy asked
fake suede to delete the account
associated with creator code orange fake
suede told him to get lost
Wars guy says that he first went to epic
to try to shut the account down and then
when that didn't work he tried to shut
down his twitch account since that's
allegedly directly connected to the
orange guy creator code his theory is is
that if your account remains dormant for
more than
month epic games will shut the code down
now I haven't found any evidence to
support or deny this so okay now fakes
way says that the orange creator code is
shut down but as of this week it's still
active and somebody is still collecting
money off fake sways says his fortnight
account got IP banned a few months ago
because of this whole situation so it
can't be him I got bond on fortnight
because of him was epic for I was him
because I created his code I got
hardware ID bond on my computer I had a
contract epic and explained situation
and then uh both the like my PC and like
my console or both like a lot to say for
now and I was IP bun so I had to like
contact my provider and have my uh IP
address changed and then I had to get
another PC but or you guys calling BS
and says that fakes ways account only
got banned a few days ago
fakes my sent me a screenshot of an
email from epic saying he was banned but
it doesn't include the date or say why
he was banned at all and orange guys
sent me a screenshot that shows at some
point 13k was paid out from the account
associated with creator code orange but
since then another 6k was donated and
seeing how that was almost four months
ago who knows how much money is in that
account right now I don't really know
what the hell is going on here but fake
sway probably shouldn't have control of
an account that isn't his but this
speaks to a more concerning issue
apparently it's super easy to manipulate
the support a creator code program and
well I don't really have any concrete
solutions besides a like
are you sure screen before checking out
epic definitely needs to do something
here thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]